okay so let's now continue digging into
the Easter thing
slowly but surely we've learned that
Donald Trump wants to let her rip very
very soon and get the country open back
up he wants to do it on Easter
now the absurdity of talking about
opening up a country where 30 states
have not closed anything down is
ludicrous and incredibly dangerous I'm
getting emails from people in Amsterdam
where there are some provisions in place
until June 1 in the Netherlands hearing
from people in Italy Spain so many
places they are horrified by what Donald
Trump now wants to do so they want to
open it back up before 30 states have
even done anything but they also are
talking about opening it back up when
the death toll is exploding it's growing
exponentially we have case numbers
growing like crazy and of course the
more we test the more cases we will find
because we've been under testing but
Donald Trump is being very clear now he
wants churches packed by Easter Sunday
April 12 so look at the evolution of
this Sunday night Trump tweets we can't
have the Cure be worse than the disease
we've already covered that with you
Monday he tweets people want to work and
we've got to get him back to work showed
you that tweet earlier Tuesday Fox News
townhall Trump floats for the first time
I'm looking at Easter April 12th and
then after yesterday's Town Hall on Fox
News Trump was interviewed also on Fox
News by Bill Hemmer and he said I want
churches packed on Easter here's the
video and you'll notice also Trump has
adopted a new voice which I call Corona
voice it's a very unusual delivery which
he uses when talking about coronavirus
related stuff that makes no sense
usually he uses a voice that I think he
thinks sounds empathetic it sounds very
very fake but when he's delivering news
that that equates to people are gonna
die Trump has adopted what I call Corona
voice take a look take a listen
we are Town Hall today you threw out a
date where you think America can be
working again and that's Easter Sunday
that's 19 days from now how did you come
up well it's 19 days but add another 7
because we've been doing this now for 7
so that's from the time we heard about
700 time we yes it's around the time we
close
so you could add seven tonight look
Easter is a very special day for me and
I see it's sort of in that time line
that I'm thinking about and I say
wouldn't it be great to have all of the
churches full you know the churches
aren't allowed essentially to have much
of a congregation there and most of them
I watched on Sunday online and he was
terrific by the way but order line is
never going to be like being there so I
think Easter Sunday and you'll have
packed churches all over our country I
think would be a beautiful time and it's
just about the time line that I think is
right it gives us more chance to work on
what we're doing and I'm not sure that's
going to be the day but I would love to
aim it right at Easter Sunday so we're
open for church service and services
generally on Easter Sunday that would be
a beautiful thing my instinct is that if
indeed churches are packed on Easter
it'll be funerals not for Easter service
and I asked yesterday on my Twitter
account is there any metric or data
point that anyone can point me to that
indicates Trump is right that we've
turned the corner and are now on the
tail end of the as he calls it war
against the invisible scourge or scourge
as he has referred to it I was hoping
someone would point me to something like
even even if it's a weak case for having
turned the corner I was hoping someone
would respond to me on Twitter and say
look at these numbers look at those
numbers we have turned the corner but
nobody could and I looked at the numbers
again this morning cases are rising
every day the death toll is exploding
every day we have more new cases than
the day before yesterday we had 11,000
new confirmed cases which probably means
somewhere between four and ten times
that in actual cases because we're
really only testing symptomatic people
unless you're rich or famous the death
toll is exploding more death every day
deaths nearly doubling from Monday to
Tuesday Monday we had 141 deaths Tuesday
we had 225 there is no responsible
metric by which we are even remotely
ready
to talk about packing churches on Easter
and again if I said this before
if Trump said listen I really want to
open up some parts of the country to
younger people on Easter not older folks
not the hot spots we got to get some
young people back to work I would say if
you want a shot at that you need every
governor all 50 governors to shut it
down from today until April 12 work with
me Trump should say in all 50 states
stay home stay home order shut down
non-essential businesses you know take
out only at restaurants spacing people
out of grocery stores all that stuff
that's what I need you to do to give me
a shot at giving you some good news on
April 12th it would still be very risky
but it might be defensible in some way
Trump saying with 30 states still doing
nothing I want churches packed on Easter
is as insane as it is dangerous as it is
irresponsible and this is the
calculation that they've made and what
it seems to me is going on is that they
are all skipping all of the headlines
that will happen for weeks and months if
they do this of the death toll exploding
of people dying at unprecedented rates
and that they'll just see the stock
market going up and they'll see an
unemployment number that's not as bad as
it otherwise would be
they'll see a GDP decline that's not as
bad as it otherwise would be
and they're envisioning getting to the
other side of this scot-free and being
able to claim some kind of heroic
victory I don't know maybe he's right I
mean as tragic as it will be is it true
that many people in the country would
accept a higher death toll to feel as
though the economy is doing better and
people are working like maybe my
perspective is wrong and when you look
at the approval polls of Trump which
we'll talk about on the bonus show today
his approval rating is higher than it's
been in a long time more than half the
country believes Trump is doing a good
job handling that's like maybe I'm the
odd man out am I the one who says Who am
I the one who is the outlier by saying
this doesn't make sense the economic a
situation that would eventually recover
an
whay is not worth killing so many
additional people maybe I'm the crazy
person let me know we're covering this
on our Instagram page at David Pakman
show while you're there if you want to
see my behind the scenes video of my
home studio setup that's on my personal
Instagram David Pakman quick break right
back after this one of our sponsors
today is VIN Chara watches giving you
15% off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch don't pay
thousands of dollars for a high-quality
watch that looks great because you don't
have to all of in Cera's watches are
made with high end materials masterfully
built and they look like something you'd
spend a ton of money on but ever even
chera watch ranges from about a hundred
and fifty to three hundred bucks i went
over to their website and picked out the
bellwether and silver and white really
nice elegant look it's a coronagraph
style wore it to a gala over the weekend
and a lot of people ask me where's the
watch from really really great look
totally different they also sent me the
altitude in matte black and red a much
more rugged view of what a watch can
look like really liked it as well as
well as the athletic strap it's a new
year it's a new decade it's time to
re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high-quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch